Barry this is the the show that you've
made it's a great idea hitman mm-hmm
comes out to Los Angeles to kill someone
follows them to an acting class yeah and
then really starts to get interested in
acting yeah yeah it's a great idea it's
a really funny idea and if we make it
like that I'm like wait what did we do
yeah no it's a really it's very
beautifully done it's really funny my
question is it's just if I had heard the
idea that Bill Hader plays not only
everybody hitman you're a former Marine
yeah like I don't know if I'd suggest
bill for that role you people you you
had to bulk up for this yeah Alec Berg
like co-created with you very good very
good writer Easter wife here we go guys
yeah we pitched the show to HBO and they
said yeah let's do it and then as we
walked out he was like you got to go to
the gym what do you mean no but I I know
it was so I went and I got a trainer and
I worked out and I dieted and all that
stuff and then I would tell people about
like yeah you know I'm working you know
you haven't yeah we got to go to the gym
this morning you know and all I know
you've seen a trainer yeah yeah ever and
they go oh cool well how long you been
doing that when you start it for six
months yeah so you don't naturally put
on muscle God someone poured pudding in
your shirt it's like it's like a dog toy
yeah there's nothing even my trainer is
like well you know you could be you know
a guy and the computer the computer guy
in the Marines yeah
that's what you're doing you're gonna
get you where you think do you think
that if you had had to have gone into
the military you'd have done okay oh no
no I I would have died like you know
like an a Full Metal Jacket the opening
where they're just shaving the guys
heads yeah yeah you would have died of a
haircut never heard of that yeah yeah
died of a haircut yeah that's that's
awful thing to tell the family
yeah and they show up yeah you know he
died of a haircut didn't go well didn't
go well did but what about I mean you've
had to handle guns and stuff like that
for for you know acting jobs for work
right and for this gig you pretty good
with a gun no no no no no I had we had a
weapon HBO was just like so wait why do
you want to play a hit man you you have
to get in shape you're not in shape you
we they gave me a gun and we shot the
first scene I did I shot the gun and
then Alec Berg went you need to come
back and look at the monitor and we look
back and no joke I'm like so and then I
gotta go I mean let's go
this did not work
you